all right hello everyone I'm here again
and today we're solving this problem pip
install my project this is all about
really providing something for your
users in Python this is a pretty good
language for a lot of users especially
new to programming for doing high-level
descriptions of their problems but it
often comes with some issues and for us
the challenge the challenge I really
like I want to use C++ I want to use C++
to provide speed to integrate with other
solutions I have in in C++ and also to
provide a sort of static static of
framework for me to work with because
sometimes you're factoring in Python can
be a little bit difficult and also I
won't install this on Linux Mac windows
there's also DBS DS but they're sort of
an exercise for the reader as a proxy
for me I'm gonna use my Kesava I'm not
very fond of using my own name so I'm
gonna use my Kesava he will show up in
where you would substitute yourself
that's a pal of mine semester with pip
install pip install is one of those
things that if you're developing Python
you're using all the time and maybe you
never really thought about how it
actually works it works in four main
steps the first thing it does it looks
up the package you're looking for in an
index usually that would be pi pi but it
can in principle be any compatible index
this is a package registry then it
determines if this particular package is
installable if it's there and can I
install it to do that it looks at the
host system it looks at your python
version and whatever is available inside
index after that it'll fetch the package
and finally extracts the contents of
this package into your side packages
directory
that's really at most package manager
it's almost a you work that way tom
package can be constructed in several
different ways I've chosen to to grow
them into four main categories you have
your pure Python this is what you would
usually want to write and especially
your downstream users you would want
them to write this so that's when you
have all Python code in your dog PI
files and it's just Python you know they
have the thing I've chosen to name in
pure Python which is almost
indistinguishable from pure Python so
this is Python code that uses a non
Python back-end probably the best
example of this is numpy numpy has a
back-end in c and you never really
notice it looks and feels and behaves by
Python all the way but it's just a lot
faster because python this is quite slow
you have what I shouldn't go thin
library wrappers so imagine you have
your system library it could be Blas it
could be a lot like it could be anything
then you then make a thin like wrapper
in Python around they would typically
operate in a sort of fire a request to
the library wait for it to finish its
routine and then parse it results pretty
much like a sir process you would treat
the library like a sub process very of
me would you see types for this which is
the Python foreign function interface
for libraries but that's not necessary
but it's done you know style of
libraries they they look very much to
like the host library that they're
integrating against and there's the fat
wrappers so they differ from the thin
wrapper is really only in the
sophistication of their interaction with
the other library is there a lot of
communication back and forth does it
maybe provide progress sometimes there
is input/output you modify state and you
do all of this but from a Python setting
big difference between this and impure
Python library is that the fat library
wrappers typically target something that
is also available from other programming
languages were asked in the impure
Python case in the umpires case the
backend is really only available in
Python this hope will largely cover the
impure Python and fat library wrapper
setting but it is also applicable to
attend libraries this is a packaged
Python it's it's from the terrarium in a
toccata in Bergen which is not my
hometown and I just wanted to share that
so the question is one is actually
inside a package what's in a package
this is a pretty common layout I stole
this from the docs python.org
listing but your run-of-the-mill Python
project would be laid out like this you
have some metadata in terms so in like I
read me you have a license file some
requirements that you wouldn't into
being installed with the package you
have Docs and hopefully you have a lot
of tests and of course it's the my
package in this case sorcerer actually
this is where all the source code goes
python is pretty opinionated on how this
source code directory should be laid out
because python libraries are religious
directories with a specific structure
that Python the knows how to interpret
okay so we let out a project like this
and then we run the setup script we'll
go into the actual details of the setup
script later but when you run that you
will get with the command B this wheel
which means binary distributable wheel
or something you would get voice really
a zip file in these guys if you just
list the contents of that you will see a
lot of files that weren't in the
original source directory like the
metadata the wheel and a record but
there's also the license file and of
course our source files pip knows how to
take this structure unknown packet into
your side package directory which is
where Python stores its libraries and
you will see here the my package from
their source directory being laid out
next to an umpire to pandas terminus at
and all your other installed
Python libraries and that's really what
a package is right it's just this
intermediary format that you can give to
someone that their tools would know how
to unpack into something that they
cannot just run this is the Pantheon in
Rome arguably one of if not the most
gorgeous building in the world if you
haven't seen it then order a plane
ticket right away I'm bringing that up
because the Pantheon is a living piece
of history in Rome and it's quite
important to understand and appreciate
history in order to provide some context
on to why things are the way they are
today history is is that context so
let's look at my for Python packaging in
the late 90s Python the Python community
realized that they wanted something like
the sea pan for Perl comprehensive Perl
archive network Sipan is arguably one of
the reasons Perl had such a massive
success in the 90s and it was pretty
glorious it was very easy to get and
obtain and use software and there was a
massive wealth of packages available and
Python didn't wanna be any worse they
wanted to win the script language force
so they developed dis to tails and
released it for the Python 1.6 standard
library unfortunately the standard
libraries where modules go to die so it
didn't scale very well as time went on
in 2003 in the pi PI the Python package
index comes online to be a proper
alternative to to see pan and this
tutorials is taught how to create
package metadata for this index this
goes on for a few years until syllabus
comes it tries to extend and replace
these two teens really asked a de facto
full tool for Python and it pretty much
wipes the floor with this UT also it
adds a few options and but it does
extend it and then later in 2008 to pet
now goals on top of set of tools and
papers the way to manage your Python
packages one thing you can notice with
this is that everything builds on
everything right which is great because
if you had a package with a script
written for dist utils in 2005 that
still works to die with set of tools you
only need to change the import the
drawback of course that means we now
have was it 20 years of legacy and that
shows sometimes in 2000 with the
distance release it already knew how to
build C extensions that like when you
see an umpire write it like C code that
behaves like any Python library but this
is largely intended for distribution and
it shows because it provides you very
few tools for development
so let's look into using setup Tomas
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
take and actually create a package from
scratch so we write our setup file this
is pretty much the minimal setup file
you can have you import your setup tools
and you invoke setup with a lot of keys
that will then be interpreted by set of
tools to mean specific things for
building and packaging so said the name
the my project name and we give it a
version we put down mecca's audacity
author because he is not a proxy and our
avatar for this we slap a BSD license on
it because that's pretty convenient and
then we list our packages in this case
we only have one package but this will
be all the modules we can import after a
package is installed this is pretty
straightforward
it reads easily and if you have a pure
Python project this is pretty much all
you need
but I want to use some say so I add a
little bit I used to sell toast on
extension module in order to declare I
want this to be a Python module but I
want it built with the C compiler so I
list the sources to my package math
thought C source file and I also extend
the setup call with the X modules
extension modules parameter this is
still pretty straightforward right so
let's actually build this math or C
extension we start by including the
Python header which is the Python API
header and we create a function add this
is just its sums two numbers and then in
fact it seems to integers the parts to
people there takes a format string from
C almost and says I want these
parameters to be integers and if they're
not integers I want you to file that's
what it says and then we create a Python
integer from nine just return it okay
then we register this function in a
function table it's just an array of
Python owns pythons own function
definition so to speak and then we
create a module definition because we're
obviously building a module you need a
module in Python with its name math it's
doctoring no I just put download your
doctoring but please be a little bit
more elaborate hear something about
interpretive states which usually should
be minus 1 you have all the states in
your global variables and then we give
it a function table and finally we have
this init function that Python knows to
look for that simply creates this module
is a very simple module with no complex
state or object going about so all we
need is the PI module create function
call this is for Python 3
but it's almost identical for Python -
so far so good
pretty simple and straightforward and as
you can see how this works you can try
this out and it will work like this okay
but I don't want to you see I wanna use
C++ so it's actually livid I'm Claire
it's the blue color very difficult to
see it's pretty low contrast from here
okay good
but anyway so at this line up there with
I didn't know accept and we changed the
nulls to no pointers just to make sure
that this is actually suppose post and
in fact it's C++ 11 okay other or not
this is the file is identical and we
modify our setup script to use the extra
compile args for C++ the standard super
plus 11 flag because we no need to talk
we want to use C++ 11 this is a little
bit problematic because this assumes
that your compiler is GCC or takes GCC
flags
clong DOS but unless we see just not so
this one I'm not the one windows the
previous one dead because he didn't take
any parameters but this will crash on
Windows this is always a not great
because one of our requirements was of
course to build and distributed for
Windows
so what do we do well we move out a
check says if this platform is not
windows we assume we have GCC style
options and really we're saying we
assume you don't have an Intel compiler
anyway so just ignore that and then only
if it's not MS we see we add the or if
it's not on Windows we add the stds it
was was 11 flank all right pretty good
right now you should work on Windows
which it does until you realize some
people use mingw on Windows so this test
is not sufficient at this point
sorry at this point you get pretty
frustrated how hard can it be to just
say I want to use C++ 11 to compile this
code right so you start and then the
more you dive into this your more you
realize that building for multiple
platforms is just not an easy problem so
this is just for compiler flies but
imagine wanting to find libraries in
non-standard locations for instance
because your base distribution is read
at 6 which is very old and you want to
use a newer version of a library
somewhere that you've installed locally
it's a pretty common use case right so
you check how do other people find
non-standard libraries well I looked at
been around on the web and I found this
monstrosity I don't even know where to
begin
honestly it makes a lot of assumptions
that are very easily broken for instance
that the library is in Lib and not Lib
64 so in very many red-hot style
layouts this will not work this will
definitely not work on a standard Debian
because it puts them behind architecture
Triplets so this is obviously this is
very brittle it probably works on the
developers machine because a spirit like
that but this just it's not portable and
this is something I see time and time
again with these set up scripts it's not
they make these kind of assumptions
because covering something actually
robust is very hard and there's no
mechanism
for controlling it as a user but then
you look at the help right for building
extensions inside of tools and then you
read this you can pass it the library
there's option which search for external
libraries separated by a semicolon which
is pretty common UNIX relic and a series
of directories to search for and figure
well with that you can they say alright
see if you have your non standard
libraries path somewhere give it to them
it's ok until you realize you also need
its include path
and then you stir a little bit more so
you call that in and say you stop mmm
and that should work fine until you run
it on Windows in which cases crashes no
recovery and you feel like this
it's very painful being that anything's
get out of it worse because building C++
comes with a lot of issues you have very
different compiler options depending on
your compiler version and of course
which compiler you using there are
multiple versions there are multiple
versions on the same machine right you
might want to use clang on a system
where the default C compiler is GCC
alright we maybe want to use a newer GCC
than the one that's in the user bin like
how do you deal with that you hunt
platform specific options sometimes you
have configuration you only want to do
in Windows because Windows has some
peculiarities that the other systems you
support don't and you have your binary
compatibility it is an endless nightmare
if you start struggling and then there's
more you have conditionals and options
in your build logic for instance do you
want to support both using and not using
Blas and then you have a fallback called
path maybe how do you do that right you
have system differences imagine you want
to use one of the most common ones is
network to host byte swapping which is
just fixing endianness on Windows
studies in the windsock header and in
the right but on Linux it's usually an
issue sign it but it could also be in
Archon net sign it I think it is and it
has like three four headers it can be in
and that's just Linux and then you have
the Mac which also has different
directories and if you want the bsds and
they support it elsewhere
you have built time dependencies and
code generation an obvious example there
might be flex and or lexan and vice on
but there are of course others and you
have runtime dependencies and they're
transitive links alright so if you're
linking against the library and that
needs another library you need to link
against that third library too and you
need to get that information from
somewhere
and then there's the problem of
development so let's assume that you
write this function it's a templated
it's just a division but I can give it a
name Dave and you put it in a math HPP
header in your project right this is a
pretty straightforward divide in C++ so
you have that and then you add the you
register it in the in the function table
add it to the module and you run it and
it works right you can divide numbers
great and then you realize that if you
divide by zero you get a floating-point
exception from your operating system and
it kills your process that's usually not
an acceptable way of having our library
and python work you would want a runtime
exception in python that you can then
deal with appropriately right you don't
want your process to be taken down
especially not from a library so you
change it a little bit to actually check
is the right-hand side my divisor zero
and if it is just raise the divide by
zero exception and if not just perform
the division all right
still pretty straightforward so you do
this and then you built okay and you run
your test again and you still get the
process termination
so what happens here is that set of
tools doesn't acknowledge the fact that
code changes in headers can lead to
changes in object files it doesn't track
that dependency which is not very
convenient when you're having templated
code which is very common in C++ that
you tend to factor out into headers it
only sees that the source files are
unchanged and never considers the fact
that headers might contribute to the
need of a rebuild and you feel like this
you scream very loud both internally and
maybe you scream some external later
then the question is is paradise lost
this illustration by Gustav Dora is
called the fall of Lucifer I think in
English and it depicts Lucifer being
thrown out of heaven this scene from
well Paradise Lost by nothing but of
course the talk name hints of a solution
there is in fact a new tomorrow so when
I discovered this it was one of the
happier days of my life I have to admit
there is a package called psychic belt
which was starting 2014 at a conference
for Syfy and the the circuit or the
sorry disciple people they build a lot
of code that depends on speed because a
lot of it is numerical and mathematical
and that's generally not very pleasant
in Python I later kind of felt that the
tools they had for building and managing
and developing this world or they were
inadequate
so they created this package and as the
it says on the readme the psychical
package is fundamentally just glue
between the set of tools Python module
and C Mike
so say what you want about see Mike
about its syntax and it sometimes
funkiness but it's pretty good at what
it does so for instance referring to the
problems we saw earlier you can find
packaged to actually detect libraries
for your runtime dependency and then of
course make against them and more
importantly see make assumes that it's
sometimes interesting to point to
specific versions of that library that's
configuration time you can find your
compile time dependencies like if you
independent flex in order to create a
parser for your language that you want
expose in Python you might want to run
Flex as a part off of your your build
pipeline of course you can link
libraries and c-max target link
libraries actually manages to deal with
transitive linking which is quite useful
once you have non-trivial dependencies
you can portably set your C++ 11 14 17
or your standard across compilers and
see mag knows how to you know sort the
flags out you can check for like what
compiler am i using in order to set
compiler specific options instead of
hoping that operating system also
determines compiler you can check those
days compiler setup have this include
file available and if so should I then
include it or set a specific flag or not
and of course you have your options for
a built-in runtime like do you want to
build shared libs do you want to link
statically you can you can do this this
is what it looks like this is once I
could build looks like in practice and I
have to say it is remarkably similar to
the pure Python set of tools example the
only difference is that you import SK
build for socket build instead of set of
tools
that's it this is really it so Python
the Python del script is actually not
really aware that you're relying on C++
code that's all and this is to see make
lists that Peres said so I'll just go
through it okay you'll specify your
minimum version that's very useful in
order to know what features you can at
least use and that will throw the
appropriate error from C make you say
that I want to use C and C++ language
and linkage and in my case now set the
eleven standard then you find package
this Python extensions thing now that's
psychic bells own C make magic thing
that you need to just include that
should always be there and then you add
your library as a module like you would
do with NEC see my project make sure to
call this Python extension module
function which is provided by the Python
exemptions CMAC module from socket belt
and then of course I've just demonstrate
Harry there you can check for compiler
you can do anything because this is just
a regular C make invocation finally
install your target into your Python
directory your package directory if you
want to link against anything then you
just find package for that hopefully it
provides the CMAC file for you or at
least to see my config for you and you
just link if satellite would have had
any other things he needed you to link
against or any definitions you needed to
set anything you needed to include in
particular that is now handled by the
target link library logic in ce mec it's
a much improvement from the fine dakota
paths that we saw earlier okay
as i mentioned sometimes you want to use
specific versions of a library and see
make assumes that you want to set those
from the command line at configure time
and of course sake build allows you to
do that by we're after the double dash
you can now pass just regular c make
arguments is it regular c make arguments
to say look for set lib in
that directory remember this from before
if we had done this but with psychic
build instead this would have been the
outcome instead which is probably I'd
hope to see a last time
so we're just gonna have a brief
Intermezzo from the psychic both because
after everyday work something like this
is what you want to be doing they should
be enough for your development you want
one entry point you want one command to
just do everything for you okay you
don't want to have to manually remember
and run multiple build system in
sequence that should all be handled and
out automated for you so of course you
know we do that and how we do it is in
our case my job we use Simek for this we
you see make us our sort of puppet
master to control everything it didn't
have to be it could have been it could
have been scones it could have been
basil it could have been bill - it could
have been any of the others but for us
it seemed like and it worked very well
for us so let's assume we now have a
project that laid out like this we have
a core library here that everything
depends on we have our Python library
that also depends on the core library
right within my package that we saw
before and just for giggles I added
another language to see you have all
this you know built sari languages in
parallel language support in parallel
and each of these directories come with
their own cmakelists file that then
manages how to build you know from their
own town so let's look at what that
looks like for us so we are what we call
a custom target custom target in cement
behaves like your ad library or your ad
executable except that is always
considered out of date so Simek will
always try and rebuild it we give it
that we give the target a name we want
it to be included in all so we don't
have to say you have to specify that we
want it built we want it always built
and we specify in pythons case that we
want to run this in the source directory
of Python Python tools are very in my
opinion obnoxious in that and then they
tend to already pollute the source
directories a lot and do a lot of their
work in source directories because
Python is just source code in its
distributed form anyway
so we do that in order to choose the
path of least resistance and you don't
want to spend much time fighting both
systems so we had a command where we've
had the path to our Python and the path
to the setup file and we run build
extension with in place and I said we're
now polluting the source directory but
psych it built already masks not beyond
its own escapable directory so that
multiple builds in the same tree for
multiple pythons will already be in two
separate directories anyway so it's not
that big of a deal
and celebrants will regardless pollute
your directory and it's kind of accepted
in the Python community so I consider
that a recent trade off and we run the
build but we make sure that this emic
executable is the same as the one that
invoked me and the generator is the same
so if you ask for a ninja you will get a
ninja also for the the python extension
and then we pass the path to the cord
that we now depend on as a parameter to
see Mike so that it tries to link
against the freshly built core library
right so that if we do make changes in
our you know development tree that will
be picked up by the package we're using
our path for that here as well but that
of course is something you wouldn't do
when you install then you just rebuild
it without our path which is quite nice
okay and that's really it now it's
always pulled after core so that
dependency ordering is in place and it
just defers all the work and decision of
building Python to setup tools it's
granted it done is invoked every time
even though there's nothing to do in the
Python extension but checking that is
pretty quick because that you used to
see Mike and just a teensy bits on logic
so it's not that much of an impact on
performance okay the next step is
building stuff and building it in
parallel and testing it
so here we have a picture from shipyard
in Belfast
that's the Olympic and the Titanic and I
think it's pretty fitting analogy for
what we're about to do because one of
those had a very long and happy life and
one well didn't because we want to build
everything I know but not build it
everywhere so this is pretty good this
is what we came out here by running
Sutter Pine Belt we can build our
project and we can test it with
certified tests but in my opinion is is
still a little bit too manual right it's
way too manual because now I need to
actually go in somewhere and type that
command but remember we support three
operating systems and we support
multiple Python versions and we've
learned one lesson over the ice right
and it's not things that you don't do
automatically you just won't do right so
anyone experienced that presumably but
you supposed to test for 10 platform be
your test on your one the one you're at
right - Ramon that we want to automate
it so what we do is we use a CI service
in our case most of our projects are
open sourced so we use cloud providers
for that we have we use travis circle a
layer i think we use both pipelines and
those one more they're all pretty much
the same thing but the gist of it is
that they will check out your code
whenever you do something and they will
run through a job and we'll go over that
so we have first the machine definition
I've chosen to call it so in this case
we're saying we want a machine with
Linux we want to test it in your Python
context and that context is of course is
provided by Travis and I want to test
these versions to 735 3 6 + 3 7
obviously actually this won't work for
this project because it's Python 3 only
but that's how it should be so this now
specifies the machine and in fact it
specifies four machines one for each
Python version and then we have a script
that it should do we wanted to install
our requirements
and we install another one that we just
run out there which is called bandit
which runs some static analysis on it
and the nice thing about that is that
when we do something we don't have to
remember to run bandit because it's
always done that and more importantly
third-party contributors to our open
source project don't have to deal with
the fact that we also would like to do
static analysis on their code because we
do it for them and that helps the
contributor experience tremendously if a
new developer joins your team and wants
to contribute something wants to do some
work a lot of these details that takes a
long while to get into habit is also
done for you so we have a massive safety
net and then finally we do the thing
where we in our case run CMake make and
we test it so this is now done all the
time on on Travis jobs are triggered by
changes to the repository okay so
whenever there's a new pull request
whenever there's a new commit whenever
there's a new merge and whenever there's
a new tag and get these jobs will
trigger I mentioned we also used a fire
and circle and that's in order to also
cover the Mac and Windows both from
multiple versions of the Python runtime
but also multiple versions of the
operating system sometimes this is what
it looks like in practice this is from
one of our projects where I have merged
I didn't find an open one when I made
this server here you can see eleven jobs
have been run to test different
configurations with different parameters
and different levels of strictness
they're all successful so I'm pretty
confident now there are no new and
obvious problems introduced by this it
helps us catch errors very fast and it
helps us move very fast and honestly I
would never develop without it I think
it's time to reinvent the wheel this
illustration shows up if you google
reinvent the wheel I don't know what it
is
but let's reinvent the wheel so the
wheel is the format for Python packages
I would recommend you use these dice it
has a rule set for communicating what
exactly it is it requires a name and a
version you can optionally add a build
number it requires your Python version
your ABI version and or a sorry API name
rather and then your platform this is in
order for pip to know am I able to
install this package so let's go back
and we run the project again we run the
build to be this wheel on my debian 10
Boston machine and it creates this wheel
and you can see it's the name and
version the Python version in the Python
ABI and my platform and this these are
the content ok it has the init and the
core as we saw and this now math C
Python Linux dot s oh right so that
would be the extension and then the
metadata why you saw before this is sort
of the anatomy of a wheel there's a
problem because we've already linked
against that Lib and there's no set
label on the user machine at least not
an appropriate set Lib so how do we
solve that right well we distribute
settle it with the wheel and you just
bond there in there
there is a tool called audit wheel which
does exactly that it looks at what
libraries do I need to load this module
all right I'll grab those and I'll put
them inside the wheel that's exactly
what it will does and then when you look
at the contents of this wheelhouse after
running this on my debian 10 machine you
get this so the big change here is the
dot Lib directory which including
includes Lib standard C++ Lib C Lib math
and live GCC ass we're going to whine a
little bit oh and yes also of course
lives at which is the one we wanted to
make sure this now actually included the
transitive dependencies - it's quite
nice just to brief note we wanted to
automate everything right but we had a
manually set version number before that
does not work because you will forget to
update that number whenever you release
in your package fortunately there is an
extension to setup tools which is called
setup tools SCM that if you specify use
SCM version in the as a setup parameter
it will pull the version the last tag
it's orden de correo new is tag it saw
and write that as the version file with
that and you never have to think about
version again and we have a single
source of truth which is the get tag and
it's or arguably or maybe even obviously
the most authoritative of any piece of
information in terms of versioning for
your project so we're lowering boats
because we're very close to the target
and when you if you did whaling in the
18th and world in 19th and 20th century
that's what you would do when you would
spot a whale you know the classic there
she blows
you will then lower your boats because
now it's hunting time this is an
illustration from from Moby Dick
we're close to the target and were you
know going for the kill problem is as
you notice the name of the wheel was
Linux right Linux is not a
redistributable because there are many
different flavors of Linux and merited
many different versions of both the
kernel and core libraries and they tend
why that might not be compatible
fortunately the point on packaging
Authority the pipe I have this
definition called mini Linux and the
idea is if you've built right your
library on a very old system for a very
old Lipsy generally it works everywhere
it's a pretty good observation they call
that the mini Linux dance the
specification released by them and if
the image was many Linux it would be
redistributable right so I could install
this wheel on my buster machine but I
wouldn't be able to give it to someone
else and have it in have them install it
so if I run the same thing on a reddit 5
machine right that we did on buster we
would actually get a mini Linux wheel
out ok but I don't have a rabbit machine
with right at 5 and I don't have a
Windows machine and I don't want that
machine running just to be able to build
and distribute my library so 100 rest ah
well there is a very good reason for me
to use two-faced machine definition when
I talked about the Travis job because
Tyrell at 5 is just another machine and
the wailing theme was not by accident so
what the Python packaging authorities do
is that they distribute this docker
image with read at 5 compilers and some
pre-installed pythons intended for
building these packages for any Linux
and we already have an infrastructure in
place to do this automatically which is
our CI pipeline so that's what we do to
automate that there is a fantastic
package on the web called multi build
it's pretty much designed to use we use
my gift clone that automates a lot of
this setting up or getting their docker
image getting into it building it in
there copying back out all not Janice
Matthew breath is built-in maintain it
he is very helpful
it's kind of a message if you need
anything but if you put this in your
before install this is all from the
documentation you source the common
utils under Travis snaps it determines
if this is a Linux or a an OSX Mac OS
job and then run the before install to
just set up the environment with that it
will pretty much build a will for you a
complete example can be seen in the docs
and finally we added deploying section
so at the end of every successful job
Travis consider if it wants to perform
this deploy it uses this conditional
here to determine if it should do it or
not and I'm saying if there is if this
build was triggered by the push of a new
tag you should do the deploy step where
it builds the package it builds the
wheel and he tries to upload it to pi PI
using my encrypted credentials and
username my cryptid password and
username and that turned this into a
true one click deploy because the only
thing I now have to do in order to
distribute my package to every platform
for many different Python versions is to
push a new tag or do that create release
on github there's this tree one click
deploy because of that and of course I
know this will will work because I've
already built and tested it through
every single commit since you know rust
last release and here's our end game now
with all of this you can run Pippin so
my project for fun and profit
this is my cassava distributing stuff
for us he's a little bit old-school one
uses his CD
so let's look back or we just saw so
we've created a package okay we built an
extension on multiple platform with C++
we assemble the wheel we bundled its
dependencies from multiple platforms and
we automatically test it and publish it
it I wrap this up into an actually
runable example you can fund it at
github slash a queen or a socket build
example it's pretty much complete
although the code in Olin is it's
trivial but it's a pretty good starting
point if you want to build a Python
library with C++
finally I want to give a big shout out
to the main sort of tools I go in today
its socket built from the disciple crew
the maintainer czar very helpful if you
have questions or patches for them
they're very grateful to which provides
the set of tools and seemingly it's a
shout out to Matthew Brandt and others
for multi builds to automate the wheel
building in CI context and of course the
serve tools sem for actually making our
lives livable dealing with versions
because i may or may not have updated
the wrong number very many times thank
you
[Applause]
I think we might have time for some
questions if you are any if not then
enjoy the rest of the conference
okay yes yes you know you have to be
like when you say mean we're not
everything if you want for it and upload
every different person yes yeah because
they use the platform tag information
that's of course your Python knows what
platform is running on because it knows
you know what system you're on and it
uses the the naming information in the
wheel to determine is this wheel
suitable for me and then it pulls only
that and then that should then hopefully
include all you need is just want to
find the package no installing
insulation candidate it'll say so if
there's a packet as only released for
Windows and I try and install that name
with my Linux machine it will just say
no installation candidate found and then
of course it will also try earlier
versions until it finds one that matches
and if none are available then it just
keeps up but I think it just says no
installation candidate any more
questions yes no no if you bundle the
the objects it also so the water audit
will really does it a copyist objects
into this dot libs directory and I think
it's such a state or path does I use
that one so it's effectively a hard
linking I static linking but you know it
will not consider local candidates if
you don't do the audit will step it of
course just used a regular loader
semantics but at that point you probably
want to build from source anyway yeah
anymore
all right then I wish you a good day and
enjoy the rest of the conference
thank you very much
[Applause]